[Musique]
et si les Bleus parvenaient à apporter
ce week-end une troisième étoile au
maillot tricolore
et demain ils tenteront de se qualifier
pour la finale en battant le Maroc et
Sylvie parviennent il ne leur restera
plus qu'une étape pour espérer remporter
une nouvelle fois la Coupe du monde
[Applaudissements]
et en cas de victoire la FIFA reversera
42 millions à la Fédération Française de
Football le staff et des joueurs se
partageront alors la coquette somme de
12 millions d'euros soit une prime
exceptionnelle de 400000 euros chacun
des primes extraordinaires que certains
joueurs n'avaient pas hésité à
redistribuer en 2018 effectivement
Kylian Mbappe a pris les devants en
disant voilà moi je vais la donner donc
pour une association dont il est l'un
des parents alors 400000 euros de prix
en cas de victoire des Bleus à la Coupe
du Monde est-ce bien mérité
alors 400000 euros de prime en cas de
victoire des Bleus à la Coupe du Monde
mérité ou pas bah oui bien sûr
franchement c'est mérité évidemment la
plupart ils redistribue cette prime il y
en a qui garde une partie ce qui gagne
un peu moins d'autres faut savoir que
400000 € pour ces joueurs de foot ça
représente même pas un 13e mois ça c'est
une réalité donc moi franchement ça ne
me choque pas et puis attendez la Coupe
du Monde c'est quand même un business
avant bien sûr ça brasse des milliards
d'euros c'est les acteurs principaux de
la Coupe du monde
et des millions
ils ont 25000 euros par match mais c'est
les clubs qui les salariés et là c'est
la FIFA donc la Fédération
internationale
il va donner 40 millions au vainqueur et
c'est redistribué il y a eu un accord
moi franchement ça me scandaleise pas du
tout c'est vrai que beaucoup quand même
Bapt redonnent alors juste remonter le
sol 400000 c'est beaucoup les mecs
pourquoi parce que
oui alors quand il rapporte en Ligue 1
toute l'année ça jamais critiqué le
salaire d'un Mbappé jamais grosse
salaires des footballeurs mais pour une
coupe du monde c'est c'est ta nation moi
j'ai du mal à toujours avec le côté
nation c'est pas pour défendre ta nation
400000 balles pour 3 semaines moi
personnellement ça me paraît beaucoup
quand je sais moi que dans le milieu
amateur la FFF et Gilles il peut
confirmer
et le amateur il donne rien il donne des
miettes
il y a certains clubs ils achètent leur
ballon tout seul leur chassume tout seul
leur fringues tout seul gris peut
confirmer parce que Gilles il est dans
ce que fait Daniel dans l'émission aussi
excuse-moi non mais 400000 c'est
beaucoup moins voilà après
je peux te répondre moi je dis que quand
on sait que la plupart vont reverser cet
argent que si ça se trouve il y en a qui
veut dire moi le lycée là je le prends
par exemple ben ils sont pas obligé de
reverser la karaté de mettre la pression
arrêtez de mettre la pression
privée en plus de l'argent privé les
gars donc en fait on s'en fout c'est pas
comme on parle tout à l'heure on parlait
de la guerre en Ukraine et de l'argent
public là c'est pas pareil là je te
comprends pas Raymond par contre au
final comme comme l'a dit comme
d'habitude
c'est très partagé